on-screen gaffes witty one-liners and
Wednesdays smiling the Wednesday blooper
reel has fans buzzing it's been an
awesome month for Tim Burton's Wednesday
with the show reportedly smashing
streaming records and stealing the
hearts of both critics and Netflix users
but now for many people it's time to
welcome the always terrible post show
Blues that's a way to deal with them
Netflix has decided to toss Wednesday
fans and users of bone in the form of a
blooper reel which is making viewers
love the cast even more in a December
8th tweet Netflix's social media team
posted a clip writing Jenna Ortega
breaking character is by far my favorite
thing this week on December 11th a
streaming giant chose to post the whole
thing tweeting enjoy the full Wednesday
blooper reel you're welcome after the
first season of Wednesday one of the
main things that viewers have been
applauding is Ortega's deliciously
deadpan delivery I find social media to
be a soul-sucking void of meaningless
affirmation so seeing her more comedic
light during the blooper reel has been a
real treat for fans right off the bat
when viewing the Netflix blooper reel
it's easy to see just how much fun the
Wednesday cast was having on set
especially when you watch Jenna Ortega
goofing off and breaking characters so
often in a comments that prompted more
than 6 000 likes one YouTuber wrote it's
hilarious seeing Jenna smile while
dressed as Wednesday since Wednesday
rarely ever cracks a grin yet another
blooper pointed to the fact that planes
kept flying over as they were filming
hard enough it'll go in right yeah I
tried that on people
it works every time now while all the
Wednesday atoms and Ortega stuff is fun
to watch it's actually not the most
talked about moment from The Reel so far
that award without a doubt it goes to a
hilarious on-screen gaffe
oh sorry did I hit you in the face right
now hold on are you okay season two of
Wednesday has yet to be announced but
it's obvious that Ortega and most of the
cast would likely return once it does
for the follow-up orteger has said that
she wants to see a darker version of
Wednesday who doesn't play things so
safe there's a lot of lines this one
about her ah you're saving the school
and doing whatever but for me me her
main drive with the monster was kind of
a competitiveness in addition to its
first record-breaking week in November
Wednesday also managed to become the
first English language series to surpass
400 million hours worth of viewing time
in a single week between November 28th
and December 4th it's now the second
overall most watched English language
Netflix series of all time
[Music]